Salut, c'est bien la première fois que vous me voyez en short dans une vidéo !
Vous allez surement entendre des bruits de percussions ou de musique car j'enregistre cette vidéo le jour de la fête de la musique.
Et pourquoi, ça fait déjà 9 jours !
Simplement parce que la prochaine semaine j'enchaîne avec la fin de la tournée du spectacle
et la suite des dédicaces.
Alors le but de cette vidéo c'est de vous dire ce qui va se passer cet été sur la chaîne
et par extension à la rentrée.
Je vous révèle tout ça à la fin de la vidéo.
Premier point pourquoi cette vidéo elle sort un vendredi à 17h30
alors que j'avais annoncé samedi 11h.
Simplement parce que cette année je vous avais dit dans la vidéo du premier janvier que je n'aurais pas de rythme.
contrairement à l'année dernière où je publiais une vidéo chaque jour.
C'est pas tout à fait exact car si vous avez été attentifs, vous avez vu que je faisais 10 vidéos par mois
Quelle que soit la durée du mois.
Et donc là on est fin Juin, c'est la 10è vidéo de Juin
et c'est la 60è vidéo depuis le début de cette année.
Ensuite, et je vous donne le programme après, j'ai fait un partenariat sur la chaîne en début de semaine dernière.
C'était le premier sur les 426 vidéos qui existent sur cette chaîne,
et j'avais pas prévu de vous en parler et puis suite aux commentaires je me suis dit "bah si c'est cool, on va en parler vite fait" !
Le premier truc à prendre en compte c'est que si j'en ai fait qu'un seul sur 426 vidéos,
c'est pas parce qu'on m'en a pas proposé.
C'est parce que je sélectionne quelque chose de cohérent, quelque chose qui a du sens pour vous,
quelque chose qui peut vous intéresser et quelque chose en lien avec un sujet de vidéo que j'ai envie de faire à la base.
Et c'était le cas de cette vidéo, vous verrez que si vous enlevez toute la partie partenariat, elle tient debout de la même manière.
Vous m'avez demandé si y'en aura d'autres,
Boui j'en sais rien, peut être...
en tous cas une chose est sûre c'est que je n'ouvrirai jamais de teepee, je ne ferais jamais d'appel au don sur la chaîne.
Y'a quand même une logique économique si vous voulez plus de choses.
Et je ne veux pas recevoir de dons des abonnés, je n'aime pas ce concept, moi personnellement.
Je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas bien pour les autres, je dis que ça ne me correspond pas, ça ne me met pas à l'aise.
Donc les partenariats s'ils sont fait de manière cool et créative avec des bonnes personnes je trouve ça intéressant.
Et le dernier truc sur les partenariats, enlevez vous le fantasme de la tête des trucs à genre : 10 000 euros ou 15 000 euros ou j'en sais rien,
Ce n'est pas la réalité, c'est pas le cas dans les propositions qu'on me fait.
Bref, on est bien en France, ce n'est pas grave de faire des partenariats, tout va bien !
Alors, cet été il va se passer quoi ?
Ben déjà dans un premier temps j'espère qu'il n'y aura plus de bruit dans la rue
et dans un deuxième temps pour comprendre ce qui va se passer cet été il faut que je vous parle de la rentrée.
A la rentrée il va y avoir une sorte de relance de la chaîne.
C'est quelque chose que j'avais fait le premier janvier de cette année, c'est quelque chose que j'avais le 1er septembre également de l'année dernière.
par relance j'entends : me poser, tout mettre à plat, me réorganiser,
retrouver un planning, retrouver un projet qui est toujours dans le mentalisme, mais voir comment je m'organise,
est-ce que je ne peux pas faire d'autres vidéos.
Les 2 dernières fois quand j'ai fait ça, ça m'a motivé à mort.
Et ça s'est senti sur la chaîne, et ça s'est senti aussi de votre côté par rapport au nombre d'abonnés qui nous ont rejoint,
salut les gars, et les filles ;
Au nombre de vues de la chaîne, à l'interaction et quand je lisais vos commentaires.
Et je pense que dans toute phase créative, il est important de prendre du temps.
Donc, 2 choses en une :
Dans un premier temps je vais faire pause personnelle durant 2 mois, mais durant ces 2 mois vous aurez
une vidéo sur la chaîne tous les 2 jours.
C'est pas très logique, je vous explique : Là en un an et demi tout pile j'ai sorti 426 vidéos,
J'ai fait 200 spectacles en tournées, j'ai écrit un livre et j'ai fait des projets un petit peu à côté.
Bon, là il est temps de réduire un petit peu la cadence pour retrouver de l'énergie, plus de créativité
et de motivation et un peu de temps libre pour remettre des choses en place pour la chaîne.
Je me laisse le champ libre pour faire ce que j'ai à faire, prendre un petit peu de repos et donc me réorganiser et commencer à réfléchir la suite.
Mais j'allais pas vous laisser comme ça, donc oui cet été il y aura également une vidéo tous les deux jours que je suis en train de faire en ce moment.
Pour ceux qui me suivent depuis l'année dernière vous vous souvenez que l'été dernier au mois d'Août j'avais fait une vidéo par jour sur des énigmes.
Cet été, Juillet-Août, tous les 2 jours, les jours pairs, je sortirai une vidéo à 11h.
Donc, tous les jours pairs, une vidéo à 11h sur la chaîne.
Se seront des vidéos courts, avec toujours un petit fact rigolo,
alors ça peut être une énigme, ça peut être un truc scientifique un peu étrange,
ça peut être un truc historique un petit peu marrant, ça peut être les origines de quelque chose
si vraiment c'est intéressant.
Et ces vidéos là seront rapides, entre 1 min 30 et 4 min
bon, j'en sais rien en fait.
L'idée c'est de me dire que je ne vais pas cramer des gros sujets cet été alors que c'est moins évident pour vous de regarder les vidéos
en plus ce seront des vidéos fun, divertissantes qui se regardent comme ça sur le pouce
et en compensation vous avez une vidéo tous les 2 jours à 11h.
Vous savez les jours pairs à 11h, BIM y'a une vidéo chez Olicard.
ça commencera donc le 2 Juillet, je vous souhaite un excellent été
on garde par contre le contact en temps réel dans les commentaires, sur Facebook, sur Instagram, sur Snapchat, sur Twitter vous avez les liens dans la description comme d'habitude.
Et j'ai hâte de vous raconter tout ce que j'ai prévu pour la rentrée, je pense que je vous parlerais de tout ça fin Août.
Profitez bien, merci d'être là, vous avez même pas à quel point je vous kiffe
et à quel point c'est un rêve déjà de vivre tout ça, avec vous et grâce à vous.
Rendez-vous le 2 Juillet, Ciao !